pour débuter ce rendez vous culture vos
avis à la sortie et des premières
projections vos sorties ciné au micro et
d'élodie moines faut-il aller voir le
nouveau quentin tarantino verdict je
suis bien si bien qu'il refasse une
édition pour que les enfants ça leur
permettre de les voir quoi sert même de
le revoir
c'était très bien en 3d ça change c'est
très bien j'ai bien aimé y bon s'il ya
quand même quelques quelques longueurs
on va dire mais il ya un truc qui marche
quand je dis déjà lutte chimie et
lambert wilson qui disent des vers de
molière enfin il ya ce qu'il faut pour
être con tendre c'est un très beau film
bien emmenés par deux acteurs de talent
quand même bah c'est du super tarantino
c'est génial les dialogues sont très
très beau c'est un super film c'est du
très grand art antiguos c'est ce qu'on
peut lire alors rien dire d'autre parce
que fauves allons voir le film ça vole
c'est très très bon excellent très bien
très bien réalisé plus tard anti noé
très bon film très très très très très
très bon film up top très jouissant de
très positif voilà rien rien rien à dire
c'est super cool c'est du bon que
tarantino violents à souhait de l'humour
est vraiment génial à voir et c'est donc
à nous pour cette chronique culture
bonsoir johanna c'est bon tout est prêt
vous avez installé l'oreillette pas dans
les cases et ont été dans quelques
instants je peux vous dire qu'on recevra
charles gonzalez et céline nova teint de
la maison de la petite on accueille en
plateau avec nous marc jacobs 7e
responsable du secteur de musiques
amplifiées qu'on appelle smart c'est ça
sur la vue seulement sm arrondi ses
matchs sur la ville de montigny le
bretonneux bonsoir en face de vous fred
mériguet vous êtes chanteur et leader du
groupe malatesta bonsoir et du son pour
rester dans l'univers musical camilla
bavémont soir vous allez nous parler de
flamenco vous êtes agent de
développement culturel au scarabée de la
verrière et la salle programme début
février le 8 vendre 18 février un trio
intitulé paco el lobo
alors qu'est ce que les spectateurs vont
pouvoir découvrir sur scène alors sur
scène on accueille donc pas qu el lobo
qui est on va dire la star du trio qui à
la fois au chanteur et guitariste de
flamenco qui sera accompagné par un
autre guitariste qui s'appelle cristobal
corbel et par une danseuse réunica
valais sion et donc pas qu'aux et
véronique avons animé
quelques semaines avant le spectacle ont
des ateliers oscars avait donc sur scène
c'est vraiment un petit peu tourner à
guitare chant de gens d'argent et danse
exactement c'est complet on regarde un
petit extrait ça vous dit qu'on voit à
quoi ça ressemble synonyme l'anonymat
yann tout poil temps s'est passé
j'attendis mollesse harry caine hockey
hebdo
keyyo la pièce à piloter paco et de
lobos et donc le l'artiste qui faisait
les palmas voilà qui chante qu'on qui
frappaient des mains
il sera présent en amont du spectacle
pour donner des cours des ateliers
exactement on organise un master class
en fait de guitare flamenca avec lui le
5 février
mardi 5 février à l'école de musique de
la verrière toujours des rêves ses
ateliers alors c'est des ateliers pour
lesdites ariste amateurs à partir de 2
ans de pratique on peut s'inscrire pour
participer aux ateliers l'idée c'est
d'avoir à la fois une rencontre et un
petit temps de découverte de ce que peut
être la guitare flamenca ses
particularités dans le toucher des
cordes etc et est un peu de pratique
aussi donc faut venir avec sa guitare
ah oui donc ces foyers vaut mieux en
même temps sinon c'est du air guitar
c'est ce qu'on appelle urieta rien à
voir il ya aussi de la danse dans ce
spectacle avec véronique cavaillès idiot
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure elle
aussi viendra pour plusieurs dates
plusieurs courts plusieurs ateliers
pareil ouvert à tous exactement alors là
c'est même ouvert aux débutants sur la
danse on organise trois séances donc on
démarre la semaine prochaine
il reste encore quelques places pas
beaucoup mais il en reste et sur ces
trois séances l'idée c'est pareil de
découvrir vraiment un style particulier
de flamenco dans la soixantaine de style
qui existent donc sur la non ça va être
plutôt sur du tango flamenco
car rien à voir avec le tango argentin
qui est un petit peu ce qu'on a pu voir
dans la vidéo
non on est sur quelque chose de beaucoup
plus festif avec un rythme assez soutenu
et qui est plus adapté aux débutants
parce que
demande moins de maîtrise c'est plus
accessible rapidement on va dire donc en
quelques séances l'idée c'est que les
gens puissent s'approprier une petite
chorégraphie découvrir un tout petit peu
l'histoire du flamenco c'est aussi le
but de l'atelier
et puis s'initier à tout ce qui est
palmas sa patte et eau etc nous a plus
de 2
succès la danse que la guitare où se
débattent pour la danse c'est vrai qu'il
ya pas de prérequis donc forcément c'est
plus accessible sur la guitare faut
quand même avoir un peu pratique et sur
le on a moins de places en guitare quand
on danse
parce que pour que chacun puisse
profiter pleinement de l'atelier on est
obligé de restreindre un petit peu le
nombre de personnes alors on va rester
dans le domaine comme ça de l'espagne
avec le barbier de séville qu'une pièce
de beaumarchais et qui a été mise en
scène par jean daniel laval metteur en
scène du théâtre de montansier à
versailles il a mise en scène ne tenez
vous bien des comédiens russie viennent
de saint pétersbourg et personne ne
parle français
je vous laisse regarder le barbier de
séville de beaumarchais jouée par le
théâtre fontaine cas de saint
pétersbourg une oeuvre française pour
une intrigue en espagne interprété par
des russes une combinaison détonante
je pense que c'est un joker mélange de
cultures si j'aime bien sa vie en tant
que futur plein de trous qu'ils aient la
seule chose qui différencie la pièce
c'est que les français parlent beaucoup
plus vite que les russes alors quand le
metteur en scène a abordé la pièce en
russe il était loin de penser qu'elle
serait deux fois plus longue que la
version française c'est simplement parce
que nous les russes nous parlons plus
lentement dans cette aventure artistique
si des comédiens sont tous russes le
metteur en scène lui est français il
s'agit de jean daniel laval directeur du
théâtre montansier à versailles
la compagnie de saint pétersbourg
connaissait déjà le théâtre versaillais
pour y avoir joué les trois soeurs de
tchekhov
alors il ya deux ans au cours de l'année
de la russie en france
jean daniel laval a proposé de les
mettre en scène dans le barbier de
séville en mousse tard je n'imaginais
pas à quel point j'avais une proche de
jean daniel et son équipe que j'apprécie
beaucoup
il y avait vraiment une bonne ambiance
et on s'est beaucoup amusé et c'est ce
que j'aime dans le théâtre quand je
travaille chez de m'amuser à son coeur
bat pour moi c'est rejeter cet échange
aucun doute la vie une belle aventure
humaine que la différence de langue doit
pas entraver jean daniel laval ne parle
pas russe et aucun comédien de saint
pétersbourg francophone ya des metteurs
en scène qui vont expliquer des choses
pendant des heures comment une personne
le personnage comment l'interpréter jean
daniel lui sait se faire comprendre sans
les mots actua seul geste pour
transmettre une idée que les comédiens
le théâtre fans d'arcade saint
pétersbourg jouera le barbier de séville
en russe
la pièce sera surtitré en français pour
le public parmi les huit dates de
spectacles toi lieu à retenir paris des
21 et 22 janvier versa et les 25 et 26
et fontenay-le-fleury le 29 janvier
camille a bavé d'autres temps forts à
venir au scarabée ya d'autres ateliers
aussi avec alors toujours sur la danse
on prépare pour la saint-patrick one
mars des ateliers de danse irlandaise
qui seront accompagnés par un groupe qui
fait de la musique traditionnelle
celtique donc des gigues des polkas fond
des choses très remuante très dansante
donc ça ce sera le 17 mars au scarabée
et voilà pour les ateliers après on a
quelques concerts aussi en venir voilà
il ya barcella la semaine prochaine il
reste peu de place donc je vais pas en
dire trop mais un petit peu plus loin on
a que catherine lara le 15 février avec
une formule un peu particulière c'est en
une avant première au scarabée spectacle
encore jamais été jouée sera jouée à
paris en au printemps accompagnés par un
orchestre yiddish de huit musiciens et
donc qui à la fois des chansons
traditionnelles la vie qui dit ch et des
chansons catherine lara arrangé avec une
autre coloration musicale une autre
orchestration donc voilà ça va être
aussi un moment intéressant 15 février
au scarabée et une belle nouveauté du
coup puisque elle viendra jeu pour la
première fois vous l'avez dit c'est la
première à laquelle jouera ce spectacle
l'album vient juste de sortir
et puis pour l'instant l'actualité c'est
flamenco on l'a vu on en a parlé